welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab podcast I'm Michael colori
and I'm Nathan only by Giles this week
we're going to show you a brand new
android phone that we're going to show
you a fake apple phone and then we're
going to show you a laser strapped to a
shark and it really happened we're not
lying but first Nathan what do you have
for us this is the HTC One X this is the
top-of-the-line you know best thing that
HTC has going and a lot of folks are
saying that this might even be the best
android phone overall the best android
phone which previous to this was widely
agreed to be the galaxy nexusgalaxy
nexus alone that is near and dear to my
heart yeah very much so I'm still
testing this out I'm not totally
convinced like you know got to put
through spaces but it's a really good
phone now we've seen the international
version of this right yes Europe Europe
version we saw that last month is that
correctly and it's pretty much the exact
same phone except the european version
doesn't run on 4g LTE networks ok ones
on you know hspa+ and it has a quad-core
processor in this one just has a dual
core processor alright so are people
gonna feel sort of left out that Europe
gets the quad core processor and the
United States gets the dual core
processor if you think that your phone
is just better because there's four
cores instead of two then you might feel
sad inside but the fact that matter is
that this dual core is still screamer
and you know the clock speeds are great
and most apps aren't even designed to
take advantage of four cores and lost
stuff anyways so really you're not
really missing out on anything alright
so if you're one of those nerds who read
suspects all the time then you might you
might be loaned out that I might be
bummed out but it really honestly won't
matter for most folks okay not at this
point so maybe in a year or two you
might see the differences in performance
later does it does it pass the blind
test right now like if I handed you both
phones without you without any way of
knowing which one was dual core which
one was quad core do you think you'd be
able to tell them apart in performance
yeah and the way that the apps actually
OS no I don't think so not yet i've been
using both and
I think they're both screaming fast and
really solid the displays are gorgeous
on both the US version slightly longer
because it has I guess more space is
needed to accommodate the 4g oh that's
barely perceptive airlie barely slightly
ever so slightly but you know it's the
same phone video nice it's quite
handsome I like it yeah it looks good
and you know the shapes kinda nice is
this single piece of polycarbonate is
really handsome yeah now a couple of
weeks ago we took a look at the other
HTC phone which is the HTC one s 1 s
right how is that different than this
well it's smaller it's actually thinner
I did like the thinnest as an aluminum
body and it displays a little bit
smaller but you know what on the inside
it's still using the same dual-core
processor processor that this one's
using it's running the exact same
operating system HTC Sense for but this
one has a way way way better screen I
mean the screen here is gorgeous it's
almost as good as the iphone if not
exactly I remember that was the kishore
coven of the 1s that well that was the
biggest thing that held it back for me
because everything else was great same
camera same 8-megapixel camera same
software but that was my complaint with
that I don't have that complaint over
here okay and then the same price
they're both 200 bucks on a two-year
contract with AT&T and while the other s
is on tmobile exact so if your t-mobile
customer that's the hot HTC phone this
was the hot one ver ett yep the 1x of
course you could always just you know
import the unlocked version from Canada
whatever you want but who does that
right for you church in montreal or i
guess a reason to go to Montreal or
Vancouver I don't know or those what
else is there in Canada Calgary Calgary
yeah where the flames are the Toronto
Blue Jays oh yeah right Toronto I used
to live there for like four years I
should be right how do you know oh well
you know it's play-acting yeah um you
can read nathan's full review of the HTC
One X on AT&T next week yeah on the
product review section of wire calm
until then you can now you're doing
hands-on yeah we're going to do a
hands-on just talking about the specific
differences here you know
TT's preloading some apps they put their
logo at the top of course and then also
have a big piece that talks about
quad-core processors vs dual-core
processors which is kind of apropos
considering the differences between the
two versions your differences there and
we're going to see more more
manufacturers putting out two phones
that are very much similar to each other
except one will have clogged or woman at
dewclaws oh yeah oh yeah samsung just
announced that galaxy s3 today and
that's going to have a quad-core
processor in it and who knows what the
US version will have I want 32 cores
someday someday maybe like a year so you
can read Nathan's review of the HTC One
X android smartphone for 18 T's network
on the product review section of the
website and you can see additional
coverage of the phone including
beautiful photos and some essays valid
processor speeds on the gadget lab
coming up next fake iphones right here
hey Mike hi Christina what is it you've
brought to show us this week this week I
have a fabulous top-of-the-line fake
iphone whoa we did a gallery of fake
apple products and there's some really
crazy stuff out there um repair to uh he
procured this in China a few years back
that is ridiculous yeah so this one this
fake iphone has three buttons on the
bottom no wait this is meant to look
like the first iphone right yeah okay
definitely it's got like a rounded edges
and the back panel looks like it yeah
and but it also has you know at the
Bluetooth logo on the back so you know
it has bluetooth oh thank god um and
let's see oh and of course like all
iphones it has a telescoping stylist
it's awesome so that's ridiculous what's
the software like let's find out so the
last time i turned this on it started
making glass crashing sounds and it
wouldn't stop until i turned it off like
digitize bad glass gushing sound yeah
over and over again about every five
seconds or so that's not a bug it's a
feature
that's what I thought to it you know
everyone in our side of the office could
hear it I felt kind of bad does it what
does look as the operating system at all
and you can like iOS it looks a little
bit like it it's loading up right now
yeah so you can kind of see it resembles
um oh yeah this is terrible this is
really bad so it's it has a touch screen
the screen sort of operates by touch but
all these weird menus start popping up
and it's got all it's got really bad
like a little sort of bad versions
attempts at real Apple apps yeah it just
doesn't work oh so how many different
devices like this did you did you see oh
man there are a ton out there so I just
picked nine or ten of my favorite ones
um one recent one is an iphone branded
stove that they found in China like a
little portable stove got the apple logo
and iPhone on there just left like a
picture the iphone or something no we
just just said iphone yeah just an
iphone brandon stove it's super weird
yeah and some other great ones there is
an iphone 5 popsicle it's not shaped
like a rumored iphone 5 it's just shaped
like the apple logo and it comes in two
flavors pair and mingo um i don't know
why it didn't come an apple flavor
though I'm yeah right maybe anyone gets
see ya Oh crosses a line we're where do
you find these things you find him like
back le great markets or what I think so
and then there's also just some shops
online there there are sneaker shops um
you know Chinese Asian that sell apple
brand sneakers that have you know
instead of like the converse logo it's
the apple logo huh so you can actually
order this stuff as like United States
citizen or is a German citizen whatever
i think so i didn't try but you probably
yeah yeah how much is that thing cost
this I'm not sure I bet it was a good
deal i bet if it wasn't a good deal it's
probably you know competitively priced
with actual
iPhones really like three hundred
dollars man i mean i paid ten bucks for
it just for the just just to carry it
around and like answer calls with it
definitely i'd pay oh that remind you
have you have you used it as Robbie used
it to answer calls or does it work in
the sky don't think so um it has it does
have a as a removable SD card them oh
yeah storage so you can load you can
load photos onto it use it as like a
photo or music player or something I
don't know yeah find some sort of use
for it I'm sure be awesome a crashing
glass sound maker it's really good at oh
that's really pitiful you can see this
stupid little phone and all of the other
knockoff Apple products on the gadget
lab and it's a gallery of how many do
you see 999 items so go and laugh and
click nine times and leave a snarky
comment because we love that speaking of
snark up next we have a shark with laser
and now John Phillips is here hi John
Mike how's it going man good you were
just telling me the funniest story about
a shark that's right shark off the coast
of Bahamas swimming around a marine
biologist named Luke tipple attaches a
laser to its dorsal fin get some really
cool photography of it and the upshot is
dr. Evil's dream of sharks with lasers
attached has finally been realized that
is crazy yep why it happen why would the
guy want to do this what possesses
somebody to go and attach a laser to
assure right well first of all we've
been waiting for a laser fide shark for
years now since the Austin Powers movie
so that's number one number two a
company called wicked lasers the company
that makes this laser actually
commissioned tipple to pull off the
stunt oh I see right so as part of a
facebook promotion so was it was it this
very laser right here no it wasn't this
laser this laser is a 1 watt green laser
the Krypton if I turned it on and shined
it in your eyes I would blind you so
very dangerous the
I would never do that I would never do
it but but I could it's armed right now
the version that tipple used was a
hundred and fifty milliwatts oh this
one's one what the one he used was 150
milliwatts and for most of the
experiment he had it set to just 50
milliwatts if a typical laser pointer is
only three milliwatts so even the laser
that was attached to the shark was still
very high-powered compared to bright
enough to see basically for the cameras
yeah and so the video shows shows the
laser in action you could see it and
that's in essentially daytime if that
video had been shot at night it would
have been brilliant so what's the
endgame here like the guy all of a
sudden attaches a laser to shore dorsal
fin who makes a whole bunch of publicity
for the company and for him I mean now
what well the end game the end game for
the shark let's start there the shark
swam away well they removed the clip and
so by the time the whole thing was over
the shark was fine it swam away no harm
no foul the real endgame for Humanity is
now we could say we've seen sharks with
frickin lasers attached and that's a win
that's a huge win what did the peanut
people think that they consider it I
didn't contact PETA I did contact a
bunch of other marine biologist Luke
tipples you know contemporaries and
colleagues I guess you could say they
were concerned about the specifics of
the clamping mechanism would it be
uncomfortable for the shark dangerous
for the shark how quickly could it be
removed how quickly could have fall off
and then one one guy pointed out that
you know if this shark has essentially a
rack of lights on its head it's going to
alert predators that might want to eat
it and also it couldn't find prey of its
own if it's shining lasers to everyone
so there were concerns but generally
speaking even even marine biologists
where we're pretty cool with the
experiment yeah seems like a little bit
of harmless fun of course we'd have to
ask the shark I was in film right it was
a docile lemon shark I don't I don't
know if it would have complained
no will we certainly didn't we thought
it was pretty cool it was caught you
could read John's whole story about the
the whole shark laser incident on Gadget
Lab and that's all we have for this week
so please join us next week we'll have
some more cool stories maybe involving
animals that have been made rendered
deadly by humans for some weird reason
and of course more cool hardware to show
you from the gadget lab so until then
take care